okay so for everyone just joining i
played an otb tournament that ended less
than an hour ago and it was at the st
louis chess club it was one of these
monthly
saturday night specials they do it every
month there was a two thousand dollar
prize fund
first place was five hundred dollars and
yeah it attracted a lot of people
um good to see like a lot of people
coming out for an otp competition
there were three grand masters there was
eduardo acobian
and robbie kev lashfili i did play ed
ward in the final round but i figured in
the stream
i'll just walk through the games and
then
i'll probably put the analysis onto
youtube so
uh the first game
i want to tell the backstory
of
my opponents
because when i walked into the chess
club
to make sure that like i was registered
about half hour before the tournament
began
this guy who i ended up playing first
round just came up to me and said he he
likes my staff for gambit content
and then then we repaired in the first
round
uh someone rated around 1400 elo
and
i got to the board maybe a couple
minutes before the round started
and my opponent
was saying that he like he's a b6 player
but he would go into the staffer just
against me
and
this was like a raided u.s tournament
and i was a little bit conflicted
because i i really wanted to go into the
stafford but i didn't want to like
rearrange the opening
and because he told me
he likes to play b6
i decided before the game
i would try and enter a nozzle wasp
gamut
by starting with d4
and this is what i played
if i play e4 like i thought he was maybe
somewhat likely to play e5 and go into
stafford
so unsurprisingly he played b6
i played e4 bishop b7
and the nozzle was gambit
is bishop g5
and this is a line i've played probably
a decent amount in like online bullets
uh
i've had 38 games here
seven times my opponents have played e6
and then i take the queen
once against uh someone rated 2 800
so i'll go ahead and say this game was
this game ended in 11 moves
but to make my opponent feel better
after the game i told him that there's
there's been very strong players that
have lost in four moves
after bishop takes d8
is it so natural for voc to pre-move e6
so anyway i played bishop g5 opponent
took a small think time control was uh
10 plus two
and um
yeah my vote took the pawn which is the
best move
this is nozzle loss accepted and then i
play d5
which is the whole point of the gambit
is to
bait the bishop out and then make it so
it can't return
and then very soon i'll develop a tempo
and hit the bishop again oh thanks
horror christian 15 5 appreciate that
uh so the game continued from here
knight of 6 knight c3
uh threatening to take and win the
bishop
bishop g6
and
i was trying to win as quickly as
possible
so i played the move queen f3
aligning with the rook getting ready to
castle
[Music]
and i checked this briefly afterwards
with the engine
an engine will give like very close to
equal after c6
but there's definitely compensation for
white like already
but my opponent played d6
which
it prevents my pawn from moving and
unleashing against the rook but
this is really weakening to the c6
square so i i was happy to play bishop
b5
and then knight d2
and very quickly we're going to see box
position
kind of
go down the drain after e6
x takes and knight d4
um
i'm realizing i'm spoiling notation here
but it was pretty quick game anyway
um here i'm hitting e6
and my opponent defended the pawn
but
just lost a rook and i took the rook
and then my opponent resigned um now i
thought before taking the rook i thought
for maybe like 20 seconds because i was
considering this or this
um
but i figured that uh
there was no reason to think for too
long and
yeah very quick aim
11 move win with a nozzle loss so uh
moving on
round two
i was black
and
i wanted to play a stafford gambit this
game
my opponent played e4
i played e5
and i was hoping for knight f3
and then play the stafford
but um opponent played knight to c3
and here i can't get a stafford
but i did manage to play a gambit as
black in just a few moves
i have six
opponent hit me with a vienna gambit
and then after d5 takes
i play e4
and here i'm the one who's gambiting
this is called the folk beer counter
gambit it usually comes from a different
move order
usually white plays
like white starts for the king's gambit
and this is a mainline faulk beer
but we did transpose
i think more common is uh
is he takes f4
but the point of e4 is it's a temporary
pawn sacrifice to try and restrict
white's development with knight f3
and
i had some knowledge here like the main
move is d3
and maybe i'll tangent for a little bit
because there's a really cool trap
i've shown a bunch in the past that if
white plays d3
there's a cool line bishop b4 bishop d2
e3
backing the pawn
but then creating the pin again
and after takes bishop d2
uh i've had a really cool game from this
position which
uh results after bishop takes c3
uh it may have even been on me chess
yeah so i've had this exact position 12
times
and in one game my opponent played
queenie chew check
and this is a really funny line because
queenie 2
[Music]
is a big mistake even though it looks
like white is just going to regain the
bishop next move
uh this is a puzzle for chat
black to move
and find the best continuation
it's a really weird opening trap
yeah also the the name of the opening
and the elo of my opponent are
it's all shown on this side maybe it's
small text but people
and still hopefully see
yeah good job to everyone saying king d7
the only way to stay up material as
black is to develop the king
the point is to threaten rookie yates
and white just doesn't have a
have time to recapture without allowing
issues on the file
uh so if takes there's this
and if bishop takes um
i think i would take first and then
again finish with this
so
we can see my uh
my online game i played king d7 queen g4
and then king c6
and the king is like weirdly safe on c6
and i hit the queen and i'm just being
up a piece
i mean now three takes takes and then
queen f6
and it's actually a white's king who's
more of a target
and
yeah this is completely winning for
black
so
it's super rare to
develop your king in the opening to win
material but
um
that works out here and just to show of
c4 i would take and uh
force a trade of queens
anyway uh during
the game i just played iphone didn't
play d3
but played a move which i don't think
i've encountered before
i've encountered once before
on d4
and um yeah it's a little bit different
because now
there's no pawn
tension and
i don't want to take on passant this
would only help white
so on poisson is not forced
at least in over the board chess
and uh yeah i've decided to play bishop
b4
opponent played bishop d2
and then here i was tempted to play e3
and like do the same idea but
i figured that the pawn is just really
going on e4 it restricts the knight
and i just castled here
and i wanted to like play rook e8 or
even e3 take some men rook e8
and then try and destroy white's whole
position
so
um here my opponent made like a clear
mistake but i think it's already a
tricky position for white
opponent took on d5
it's an attempt to win back the pawn
because if i take there's it takes d2
the problem is after takes takes
uh there's a few issues for white for
one i have queen h4 immediately which i
was about to play
but i started thinking and realized
rookie 8 might be a little bit stronger
but i think they're they're very similar
they might even transpose to each other
i started with rookie eight
and now there's two threats actually
there's like
at least three threats threatening this
or this mainly knight c3 to win the
queen
and also still queen h4
and i just didn't see any way for white
to defend against everything
my opponent played bishop e2 pretty
quickly
and i think just missed queen h4
uh
yeah things go downhill really quickly
for lights
i had to play g3
being f1 gets mated in one
and then knight takes g3
well there's this pin
and after knight f3
it still may be a little bit tricky
because i can't
easily take right away because after
takes takes
i lose a queen and wipes up the exchange
here
so
[Music]
i just retreated the queen
and then i maintained the pin
and also the bishop still pinned and i'm
threatening to take on e2
also threatening the rook
so
this is like a double pin plus a fork
so it's
like a
pin pork or something
it's very spicy
so my opponent took which is the best
try
and white has maybe a little bit of
compensation like after it takes
your uh we traded queens
and i'm up the exchange
it's basically rook for
bishop and pawn
but i won the game in just three more
moves
because my opponent uh
yeah i just misplaced one of the pieces
so
i decided to
try and complete development
and then after
bishop b5 which looks like a logical
move a6 bishop a4
e5 my opponent resigned
um i thought for a little bit after b5
but i realized that
i'm winning one of the bishops
because after bishop b3 there's a5 and
i'm going to trap this bishop in the end
uh so that was that was round two
round one i one and 11 moves
round two
after b5 i1 and 16 moves
um
now one thing like if i had this
position
as white
against like a strong player i wouldn't
resign i would still like try and find
some ounce of hope
and i was thinking during the game that
um
white could try bishop a5
after takes takes
it's really good for black blacks up a
rook for just a few pawns but at least
there's some like past pawn potential
and white almost has a pawn cube
i give this this
rook c8 d6
always a hope of mouse slitting too
so i thought maybe there's some
practical chances uh
if this were a bullet game or something
anyway that was round two
um so another
nice gambit
i was really feeling motivated to keep
it up with gambits
so
moving on to round three
round three
uh there was some pregame psychology
because the pairings went up
and
like the pairings are printed on like a
paper
score sheet and like everyone kind of
crowds around the scoresheet to see who
they're playing
and
there was this one guy who was saying
oh wow i'm playing eric
so i i knew uh
i knew how i was playing pretty quickly
and
uh it's actually super nice guy who also
like has a youtube channel
so if this eventually goes on youtube
i'm gonna try and find his youtube
channel and then link it in the
description
um and he was telling me before the game
that
i'm the reason why he plays a london
opening
and then this is where the psychology
began because i was white against him
and
i knew
i knew that
he plays london as white
so then i started second-guessing myself
if i actually wanted to enter the london
going into an opening that he he already
knows as white he's probably watched my
content
so
um
he wasn't trying to like psych me out or
anything he was just like being uh
just kind of being natural like
explaining that uh yeah he watches my
content
so i was trying to like figure out what
opening do i play like do i test him in
the london
or do i try and just avoid it completely
play e4
i was considering playing c4
but
i ultimately decided
to play a london
but then psych him out and play a job
london
and even though the openings are similar
they're a little bit different
um
and i've never played this in over the
board chess i rarely play this online
like we can see my games on each s
i've had this position
982 times
i played knight c3 12 of those times
and i'll admit it's not an opening i've
like studied so much
but it was an attempt to
[Music]
just get into unfamiliar territory and
try and just figure things out as we as
we go
so joe bava london time
and uh
my opponent played c4 or c5
which is a typical move like if i were
to play e3 then c5 is one of the main
lines uh then i blitzed out e4
and
i have some vague idea of like
of this position because
there is a game from the fide grand
prix wesley so against
amin tabatabai
wesley was black and like got a losing
position within 10 moves or something
uh maybe i can find the game
or maybe we can find it
in
yeah the crazy thing is like there's
only eight games in the masters database
but the master's database hasn't been
updated with like recent games pretty
sure there's been lots more games played
in this line recently
i think wesley's game went something
like this
knight c6 bishop b5
and
i don't want to go on too much of a
tangent
maybe at some point in the future i'll
find the game to share
but uh it's dangerous if black's not
prepared
so my opponent played
um
another very playable move
d takes e4
and then we trade pawns i took on c5
i could play d5 and this is like a true
gambit this is reverse
album counter gambit
but um
this is more of a pondraid
then here bishop d7 was played which i
think is already like some inaccuracy
uh and then i played
knight p5
and this is like one of the main
themes in job london like you develop
the knight and bishop first and there's
many positions where you just go
straight for
c7
and it's not so
easy for black to actually defend the
square
because e5 i just take it
and here my opponent fell into
kind of a nasty trap
uh well black should play as knight a6
it looks a little bit ugly but it
controls e7 and um
i wasn't sure what i was going to play
here
like maybe a3 and prepare b4
but my opponent played queen
a5 check
and
uh this turns out to be a blunder
and i think this is a good on a puzzle
again for chat this is white to move
and
punish
black's last move
i'm the best way to get out of check
ah stephen willie
steven willy remembers this from
previous videos
maybe yeah this idea has definitely
occurred in other
types of positions
so there's actually a lot of moves being
suggested there's bishop d2
c3 b4 queen d2
which shot suggesting almost all the
legal moves
it's not king e2
um yeah so i don't bond cloud
uh if i play bishop d2 this was one of
my original
thoughts
the problem is i no longer control c7
with a bishop and we can just repeat
so
the
winning move here like the strongest
move is to play b4
to keep initiative on the queen
and i i give away a pawn but then i have
c3
and now the queen's hit
knight defends the pawn and i'm
threatening knight c7
so
yeah this is much better than bond
clouding
and here black is uh is already losing
material
uh opponent took
i'll have to remember but yeah we just
have a few more moves here
knight c7
in d8
it takes eight
and then e5 was played
and actually like it's still a fight
because my knight's kind of trapped in
the corner and black has a bit more
development even though the kings on d8
uh it's hard to actually attack the king
it's hard to save the knights
so i was still
[Music]
expecting some sort of battle here
uh and i play bishop e3
and we actually
looked at the game after uh afterwards
and my opponent missed like a really
weird
engine line like it's really hard to
find
i can't blame my opponent for missing it
um in the game he played queen a5
but the engine will suggest queen takes
c3 here
uh which doesn't look so great because
it opens the c file and now the queen
has to move again rook c1 is coming but
the engine will suggest just a crazy
retreat queen c8
and after rook c1
knight c6
and then the queen will go into the
corner
and just to show engine will say like
plus one maybe
it's not a huge advantage for white
um oh there's bishop a5
oh wow bishop a5 that can sack the queen
okay still better for white
but if i if i lose a knight then there's
there's some material for black
anyway that didn't happen
um opponent didn't want to like take
this pawn and open the file queen
[Music]
a5 was played
and then i played queen to
[Music]
e3
and now i'm trying to remember what
happened next
are you sure knight c6 was played
yeah knight c6
um yeah just developing
and i can't take either undefended pawn
because
then queen takes c3
uh but here i have like another really
nice move
to actually save the knight
is knight b6
and the knight can't be taken because of
the
bishop fork
and now my knight is just surviving
opponent played bishop here hitting my
queen i play bishop c4
and this is where black's position
this kind of goes downhill
uh again i'm struggling with
what happened um
i mean we played a few more moves
essentially what happened maybe bishop
e7 i brought the knight back uh or i
traded first tripling black's pawns
i threw in the check i brought the
knight back here
and then
yeah this may have been the position
um it's already over at this point like
once i play knight p6 i'm i'm saving the
knight i'm up a rook and after 92 my
opponent resigned
so it was an 18 move game
um
and that was my first
otb job london success
wait a minute this definitely didn't
happen
because i would have realized if the
e-file was completely cluttered
but maybe we can pretend it happened
because it's a funny final position